if we take 30 000 down today okay thirty
thousand thirty thousand down today and
we do times thirty five is what that
means that will be at a million in 42
years to meaning long term you're gonna
be fine long term Innovation is going to
be fine but for people that are sitting
there saying I truly want to create
wealth you have to if you have some
savings right now you did it right
you're going to be able to capitalize
because a lot of things are going to be
on sale you're going to buy a condo a
house on nothing in my opinion in the
next 12 months the level of discounted
properties is going to be insane in 12
months like discount in a way that you
never thought you'd be paying that kind
of a discount on 12 months but you have
to also be thinking about this is if
you're if you're 30 years old this is
probably going to happen only five times
in your lifetime if you're 40 years old
it's probably only going to happen four
times in your lifetime if you're 20
years old six times wow you have to be
ready for your the next one that's gonna
happen in 10 years and the way you do
that is by piling up a bunch of cash and
you make some good Investments and 10
years from now you ready when it happens
again